[Music]
this is the story about a forgotten
genius a gifted sculptor artist and
modern-day Leonardo da Vinci whose
ufo-like invention was the realm of pure
science fiction but it's also a story
about this man his fixation with the
past and living on borrowed time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a couple of years ago I got this email
from a guy named Randy hunter who was
promising me the greatest nonfiction
story never told it was about this
inventor who lived here in the outskirts
of Silicon Valley he had done all sorts
of amazing things but he'd been
forgotten by history and for one reason
or another I bit on his email and for
the last two years I've been coming this
guy Randy Hunter's place where he has
built a temple to obsession which is
this inventor what are you doing in here
man I got another big batch of photos we
got a few minutes oh look at this yep
meet Randy a successful art dealer and
fine art collector and this is the guy
he wants everyone to know about
Alexander ygor's
[Music]
ykers was born in 1901 in the Dutch East
Indies as a teen he moved to Europe to
study engineering and then moved to the
u.s. to study sculpting near the end of
World War two ygor's settled in Carmel
California and it's here he carved out a
most unusual life he built a house made
entirely from recycled materials and
objects crafted by hand in his
blacksmith studio ygor's ability to live
off objects that other people threw away
turned him into a cult figure
youngsters traveled from around the
world to take his tool making and
sculpting classes they also came to
marvel at his art this is probably the
most photographed wire so far Randi
discovered ygor's in 2008 when for the
first time his sculptures were put on
sale Randi snapped up the lot as an art
dealer he had dreamed of hitting it big
by finding an unknown artist and making
him famous and figured that ygor's was
his man this sculpture is my favorite
but what started as a business deal
turned into a life-altering passion over
the next 10 years
Randi spent countless hours and millions
of dollars
tracking down ligers sketches personal
belongings and all the finished artwork
he could lay his hands on he produced a
movie about ygor's wrote a book about
him and became convinced he discovered a
hidden genius
[Music]
what draws you in what makes you
fascinated about this man I immediately
fell in love with him because it was
just like my style and I could see that
death and his work immediately and he
needed to be shared with the public
the version of Randy you're seeing is
more sedate than the affable chatty
salesman I first met in late 2017 he
started to lose a multi-year battle with
cancer and painkillers made it tough to
get around and think straight go ahead
sure a few months ago his cancer came
back and as you'll see he's not at his
best he's not the same guy that he used
to be and it's a difficult part of the
story his whole mission has been to make
this ygor's man as famous as he can be
and Randy might not get to see the end
of that story
this is his drawings blueprints okay how
do you find all this look at this man
this is all these letters digging man
[Laughter]
during his hunt into ygor's life
Randy discovered something extraordinary
hand-drawn designs for an exotic
aircraft dating back to the 1920s
Alex appeared to have invented the very
first flying saucer that was amazing
fine in itself when I saw the blueprints
it was undeniable that he was the
creator ygor's called his futuristic
flying machine the disc copter designed
to take off vertically and float on a
cushion of air it was a unique concept
and one he thought cities of the future
would make full use of
viger's patented the disc copter in 1944
and then tried to sell it he starts
sending all of these letters to all
kinds of companies telling them about
his invention
[Music]
his word of the diss copter began to
spread Alex felt the US military stole
the idea it was an accusation they
denied but for ygor's evidence of the
theft was there for all to see as images
of his flying saucers seeped into
popular culture influencing everything
from architecture to cars and movies a
two-seater in ready suit may be the car
or chopper of the future there's this
whole flurry of stories ygor's first
with saucer Dutchman says he designed
flying saucer 23 years ago the man who
invented the flying disc he would didn't
really seem to be after compensation as
much as recognition that he'd done
something important and wanted a bit of
credit for it
[Music]
spoiler alert the disc copter never
became a reality
but the flying saucers that inspired
LaVon in Randy's collection of UFO
memorabilia this is the room that I
think of is the ultimate Randy room this
is the tribute to the disc copter you've
got books you've got toys everything you
could ever imagine about UFOs to me this
room is always represented the heart of
who randy is he's this guy with a
passion that I think we would all envy
and hope to have for something but also
that bit of his character where he can
go too far and gets obsessed to the
point where some people I think would
think these little nuts how is your
family and friends you've gotten deeper
into how crazy you are I think depends
on how much money you spend on your
project a couple of years ago Randy and
his partner Kathy forked out 1.6 million
dollars for the land where ygor's used
to live well the original house is gone
Randy's been busy turning his new home
into a temple to all things ygor's this
is Randy's workshop and this is the room
that I think ties him and Alex together
there's a mix of Randy and Alex's tools
and the molds of weygers sculptures all
lying across the room outside work has
started on rebuilding ygor's artist's
studio and blacksmith shop and there are
plans for a brand-new ygor's museum and
a UFO fire pit is also in the works
it'll be shaped like a disk akhter and
when you're actually burning a fire it
would be obvious from 100
there's a flying saucer on this property
you might think Randy has more money
than sense
and let's face it he hasn't managed to
make Alexander ygor's in the disc copter
household names at least not yet
but in ygor's Randy discovered a kindred
spirit
a man who chose to live by his own rules
and who created a legacy using his own
two hands what would you say to Alex of
you saw him now I wondered if he had
dreamed about that moment or anything I
did dream about me and him yeah figured
it was a spirit of liars basically
telling me I'm doing the right thing and
I should continue with my mission
[Music]
you